how are you guys weeks man i just had an
absolute [ __ ] ordeal this morning
what
yeah so okay so
this is like [ __ ] what now like
volume eight of gaijin versus japanese
bank right i think i think we're like at
that volume now
the bank strikes back
and i mean like to me like now like
going to a japanese bank
is kind of like going to the dentist now
because like i do anything i can to put
it off i like my dentist actually really
i mean it's been great here the bank's
way far worse i would rather have like
an
anal rectal cavity whatever that is
opposed to going to the bank an anal
rectal cavity the dentist
honestly i agree because like i've been
putting off going to the bank for ages
right because i've needed to send money
abroad to back home okay uh because
right now i'm helping my parents pay for
the mortgage of their house so they can
retire and have a nice comfy like asian
sun
right there
just just being a good asian son as you
do um so i mean i've been doing this for
like
basically since i started youtube but
since i moved to japan obviously a lot
most of my money is now in my japanese
bank account and i've known for a while
that i've needed that i was going to
need to transfer money into my british
bank account of course i was just
dreading this right as you as you do
with any japanese bank experience um
what i didn't realize was that i was
gonna have like the biggest ordeal i've
had yet in the japanese bank
um so i mean like so i'm just like okay
i booked the appointments because you
can you can't do anything online as
we've said
on call god forbid you can yeah be you
in the 21st century yeah right yeah so i
turn up as usual and uh normally when we
turn up to the bank uh they normally
have one guy who works there that uh
acts as an interpreter because he speaks
english and japanese right
um so he wasn't there today
so they just let you do the appointment
did you do they know
yeah yeah they knew it was me they knew
so so you know the guy they weren't
gonna be like uh gone thought yeah
so so it was the same woman that uh
handles our accounts but the interpreter
the guy who speaks english wasn't there
this time okay so i'm just like okay
this is gonna this is gonna like
this is gonna put my nihongo josu to the
test right this is gonna this is gonna
stretch it to the [ __ ] limits right
because
because uh i mean thankfully i i have
been you know practicing as much as i
can especially my listening skills yeah
but uh this is gonna this was gonna
stretch it to the limits um so bank hard
mode yeah this is this this was bank
like [ __ ] doom impossible mode or
whatever
so um so we start we start the process
and uh we take we take inventory and i
bring all my usual stuff right uh i've
got my hanko got my bank book got my
bank card got everything fully prepped
yeah fully prepped i'm like i'm
experienced i'm a i'm a [ __ ] japanese
bank of war veterans i know what the
[ __ ] i need to do a japanese banks right
so i'm just like i know what happened
battlefield
some like rates um
so we start the process i'm like can i
transfer money to my british bank
account please or transfer money
overseas and she starts explaining to me
the process and i'm like [ __ ] out
okay i understand like
70 of what you're saying so i'm like i'm
like great i'm following i'm following
what she's saying i'm like you know what
maybe maybe this maybe this will be a
smooth process
so i put in my name put in put in um put
in
my address and everything i need to do
um and then we get to the actual
transfer part of it okay the actual
transferring money to an overseas bank
and so uh she asks me uh about the bank
and i say oh it's a british bank it's
barclays um it's my account
um and then she says uh and
here's here's where here's where my
japanese got tested she said something
right and
i heard i heard transfer
and i heard purpose yeah and i heard a
connection right okay so in my mind
stitch it all together you know because
that's how
so i heard those words so i i stitched
the meaning of the word to be what was
the purpose of the translation right
right right because that's that's that's
that's naturally what i assume so i was
like oh great i'm the purpose of my
transfer nigeria
prince actually yeah
so i try to explain in the most broken
japanese i can the purpose of my
transfer is just to transfer money to
myself in england yeah i was i was like
british bank account in england my
british bank account in england
transferring money to that yeah and and
she was like no no no no and she re and
she re-explains and she re-explains
there now i'm just like
okay so how do i explain to her that i'm
going to be paying a mortgage for my
parents in england and i'm just like
[ __ ] hell okay this is this is this i
don't know you know i struggled to spell
mortgage in english yeah yeah i'm just
like i guess i'm just like i was like
mortgage
and i'm just like uh yoshino tamini
and i'm just like i'm just like that's
that's that's the most i can come up
with which is which isn't what i would
have done
which is basically uh for the purpose of
my parents i'm paying for their health
paying for their house right and she's
like no no no no and and
and and then we we we just like try to
brokenly communicate to each other and
then she just and then she whips up the
google translate and i'm just like why
don't you whip this out and i'm just
like okay here we go here we go and then
uh she she google translates it and
she's she's just like and
the translation is
do you have any evidence that you have a
connection to the purpose uh to the
person you're transferring to for the
purpose of this transfer and i'm just
like
what
it's it's me it's literally
it's literally are we it's me
it's it's me are we like
is this a [ __ ] circus we're running
here like what's going on like how how
can i prove that i have a connection to
myself right so it's like it's like if i
were you i would have been like so how
many [ __ ] got many tacos do you know
in the world yes tell me this is the
thing that i was dreading about japan is
that they just nothing's ever good
enough no no no no yeah it's like no
because because
i want to see a passport of other you
yeah because because to a japanese
person sending money to yourself
overseas is just a concept that they
don't understand it's like
why yeah so so the first thing i say was
like uh i mean my names are identical
isn't that enough proof and she was like
no no it's because it's because in
japanese bank uh your first name comes
second and your certain your surname
comes first so it's manitoba ganto yeah
and then in my british bank and barclays
is god's manitoba and because the names
don't match they they obviously
they obviously assume i'm like a dual
citizen like i'm [ __ ] jason bourne
with five different identities
wait which one no it's actually a
russian guy
so i'm just like what do i need and she
was like uh i don't know i'm just like
and she was just like um i don't know do
you have any bills and i'm like i i
don't have any bills because they live
in japan now
we're like a bank statement too yeah and
she's just like yeah sure a bank
statement will do and i'm just like
huh do i have to print it out and she
says yes of course you print it out and
it scans to us i'm just like
well [ __ ] because obviously thanks can i
borrow yours
thankfully with british banks i could
access my statements very conveniently
on my phone you can't just do this and
on any and on any electronic device and
i'm just like okay how can okay this is
where my engineering problem skills like
come in because i first first think i
asked her
like how much like
can i go to the company to print off my
uh to print off my statement right and
she says sure uh how much time would
that take and i asked how much time is
this appointment book for and she says i
have an hour
all right and the appointments book for
an hour so i have an hour yeah time slot
because i am not [ __ ] going i i am
not coming back to the bank just for the
purpose of this transfer yeah and i'm
not missing out on this appointment so
i'm like [ __ ] i'm doing this right
now and and i'm just like oh i'll be
right back i'm going to go to the
combini i'm going to print out my stuff
um print out what i could have showed
you digitally yeah yeah he could have
just done this i could have sent it to
you
email
exactly so do you have a fax you could
fax it to us so i rush off to the
company and then i realized that um so
there's so every company has a printer
right and there's only a few ways to
connect to that printer oh yeah one way
i know you see where i'm going this one
way is via phone and the other way is
via usb stick so i was just like okay
great maybe i got on my phone so i'll
just connect via my phone no so um i you
you think you will yeah
so that that's me was like my first my
first option to problem solve this
[ __ ] issue that shouldn't be an issue
yeah right so i try to download the app
to connect to the printer um the app's
not available internationally of course
i have uh i have i'm uh my google play
store is still linked to my uk account
luckily luckily that wasn't too big of
an issue because i have a japanese
account as well for this exact purpose
of downloading japanese apps right um so
obviously um i download the app and
everything is in japanese yeah and
obviously my nihongo is not josie enough
to figure out japanese
yeah my money hunger was not good enough
to figure out this app yeah so what i
did is i have a second phone right and
this translator and this second phone
is my my uk phone so i i have like this
old uk phone it's an iphone 5 which is
like my my phone before i upgraded to
this new phone now yeah um which is the
only purpose for that phone is just so i
have a uk sim card so i can phone home
or if any uk people want to phone me so
i'm [ __ ] like i'm [ __ ] on my phone
with another phone googly google
translating my phone with another phone
i've done that
i'm just looking like a [ __ ] clown in
the community being like
so i'm there for about 4 10 15 minutes
trying to get this phone to connect to
the printer yeah it just does not want
to come out [ __ ] i don't know what is
going on with the app i don't even think
it was the language i just think it was
the app i've tried i've tried using that
app and i tried for like an hour it just
doesn't connect this is why i just
always carry around the usb stick yeah
right there
you never know when you're in the
printer yeah yeah so so i'm like [ __ ]
this isn't gonna work okay i i i've 15
minutes have passed the time is ticking
i've only got like i've at this point
i've only got half an hour left of the
appointment and i also still need to
fill out the rest of the form so i've
got another 15 minutes or more so i'm
just like okay i need to find another
way thankfully i remember i bought my
laptop with me great so i can i and i
have a usb stick as well in my bag so
i'm just like great um i just need
internet so unfortunately with japanese
sims you can't tether internet no
it's like it's like an option you have
to pay for it yeah exactly exactly so
i'm just like [ __ ] googling where is
the nearest internet while uh internet
hot spots so i look for coffee shops
right so i'm like brilliant there's a
lot more like a mcdonald's or something
yeah yeah yeah yeah brilliant oh god
it's just like everything you do there's
another thing yeah yeah
it's
like a side quest to complete the side
quest yeah i have to order a drink
starbucks
brilliant there's a thali's coffee shop
like right you know i blocked down from
here so i [ __ ] sprint to this coffee
shop i don't want to buy a coffee
because that's just adding more time
once yeah i'm like outside the coffee
shop and i'm just like [ __ ] i'm just
like [ __ ] watch dogs you know like
i take out my laptop i in the middle of
the in the middle of the street i take
out my laptop open it [ __ ] connect to
the wi-fi
yeah it's like a scene of watch dogs or
something i'm just like [ __ ] off the
traffic lights i'm hacking into the
mainframe i'm packing the system so i
like downloads download my download my
statement put it in my put it in my usb
stick run back to the [ __ ] combini
then i can finally print off the
statement yeah and i'm just like and by
then 20 minutes have passed so i [ __ ]
run back to run back to the bank and i'm
just like do i have enough time to
complete this transfer she's like yes
yes we'll make enough time don't worry
i'm like thank [ __ ] god
okay
so i hand her the statement
right and she's like okay great we can
use this yeah and then so we start we
start to start we start filling out the
rest of the form so she asked me for my
british uh account number and account
details yeah and so i whip out my uh
barclays debit card and she looks at it
and she goes
oh we could have just used that
and i'm just like
oh my god i am literally about to screw
you right now
so
you know and if you ever ask a bank like
person like being like why didn't you
tell me that before then they'll just be
like well you did not
yeah i mean i'm just under the pandora's
[ __ ] box
thank you for giving me all the options
uh was there a transfer limit that you
could do uh there wasn't a transfer
limit thankfully enough but the transfer
itself cost eighty dollars which is just
like [ __ ]
well i think i think the reason why
japanese banks because i read the up on
this uh before because i had i had to
help aki do the exact same thing right
like send money back home uh for her
parents and like yeah i had to go
through this obviously i didn't have the
problem with the google translate thing
so i got it done in one go yeah but my i
was just like jesus christ like why why
is this just such an arbitrary process
like it shouldn't take this long and
then i saw like a thing being like oh
it's because japan uh has like run into
like a lot of like money laundering
issues and i'm like
i don't know if anyone can be bothered
to money launder if it takes that
[ __ ] long
to do it like not even worse honestly
it's probably a deterrent at this point
yeah like why would you money launder in
japan when
when it takes like a full day to process
i'm like i can't be [ __ ] the money
launderer anymore i'll just be a
law-abiding citizen
honestly it's probably easier to like
abide by the law than money laundered at
that point i feel like the money
laundering is is not an issue that is on
the everyday
consumer bank i feel like we should
really be looking at these messages i
guarantee a billion dollar transfer yeah
i guarantee it was probably like it
happened maybe like once or twice and
then obviously every japanese company
when something bad happens once or twice
they get super paranoid about and
they're like guys we have to stop this
money laundering crisis it is
unstoppable make the process as [ __ ]
as possible so that no one can be
bothered to do it is that really the
reason why because i i've noticed that
like anything payment wise japan is very
easy to send money to but very difficult
to get it out of and i just wondered if
that i i just assumed that was like
japanese government being like yeah we
want money to stay here yeah i mean
that's probably also a thing as well i'm
sure the money laundering is just like a
fast like like a public thing that they
just say but i think guaranteed they're
just like that's why we don't like yeah
yeah we don't want you breaking any laws